5 26 on your friday morning while reed
airport has responded that viewer email
about the speed limit in the airport
connector tunnels
after an anonymous viewer was concerned
that he's one of the few people
following the 35 mile an hour speed
limit the airport's joe rachel wrote the
decision to reduce the speed limit was a
safety measure there were nearly 150
traffic incidents in 2018 and 2019 some
of which included fatalities drivers
need to exercise more caution we believe
reduced speeds are necessary to curtail
the frequency of accidents
through the first six months of 2019
there were 60 accidents in the tunnel
there have been 19 so far in the first
six months of 2022
and joe added there were too many
rear-end crashes from drivers slamming
on the brakes coming up on backed up
rush hour traffic in the tunnels and he
says the reduced speed limits followed
consultations with clark county public
works and the nevada department of
transportation now as for folks ignoring
the speed limit joe points out uh that's
a law enforcement issue so we'll keep
bringing it up thanks again to joe from
uh reed airport for right now buckle up
drive carefully please put on that phone
you can join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic 8 8 news now dot
com